this video contains spoilers
welcome to sword art online store art
online is the greatest game ever this is
the greatest game ever you are now all
trapped until someone completes 100
floors [ __ ]
ha-ha most of you are actually guys oh
and if you die and here you die in real
life
yo come with me i need a comedic
sidekick actually i think i could be an
interesting character audiences would
like to see more shut up kwine come back
when you're a main character
two months have passed and two thousand
people have died too many people have
died so your only objective of this raid
is don't die oh god i'm dying drink the
potion this is it i can tell this is the
end drink the goddamn potion just tell
my family i love them well you just
drink the potion already
why didn't you drink the potion screw it
i'll do it myself
oh my god
who the hell is he i'm the black
swordsman no you're [ __ ] not how the
hell did it get so overpowered i'm not
overpowered
now i just need to find my generic love
interest are you the right one i guess i
could
are you the right one i'm like 12. are
you the right one i'm as useless as a
hedgehog in a condom factory how about
you tits mcgee it's not like i like you
or anything you idiot perfect hi hi you
want to get married okay you want to
have sex okay
does this mean we can have children now
god i hope not here look what i found
you've got to be [ __ ] kidding me can
we keep it no but i want one no please
no i'm not having sex with you for a
month fine if you promise to feed it
properly and take it for walks are you
my mama and papa yes no can we just go
back to showing me being overpowered
oh so apparently i can do will now hey
how is that fair shut up cline come back
when you're a main character
now no one can beat me at this game i'll
let you finish kirito but i am the
greatest sao player of all time you want
to go fight me irl bro
hex i got hacked what you're kaya
akihiko aren't you what are you talking
about obviously no one else can beat me
at this game i commend you for figuring
out the truth now fight me oh [ __ ]
seriously i was just talking out of my
ass whoopsie daisy
why because that's the only useful thing
i'm ever gonna do
i'm still gonna die you stupid [ __ ] now
you die you are dead hats mode on what
this doesn't even make sense gg no re
congratulations on beating the game so
how come you wanted to trap thousands of
people in this game i don't know seems
legit i'm gonna blow you so hard when we
get out of here okay wake up [ __ ] you
owe me a blow job i'm afraid she's not
going to wake up who are you i'm the new
bad guy of this arc who's going to marry
this girl
all right pedalman great face have fun
getting dead fish the rest of your life
hi i'm incest sorry incest i'm not
really interested right now what am i
supposed to do now have you heard
there's a new rpg out now's not the time
for games i have to figure out a way to
save awesome holy [ __ ] you can fly i'm
so [ __ ] on this what about saving
asana saving who you have black hair and
you're really good at video games just
like my brother who have very big
breasts just like my sister did i ever
tell you i was in love with my brother
wow it sure sucked if i was your brother
you're my brother i'm your brother [ __ ]
[ __ ] i can't believe i fell in love with
my brother
wait still might have a chance with me
i'm instantly over it let's play more
video games
this final boss is impossible to beat
who the hell do you think i am i'm
keratin
all right well i guess second time's a
charm this time with the power of
friendship i'm actually just a pointless
character
i'll write them through now to get you
out how do you plan to get us out by
ripping off berserk
oh you're here again wait how are you
even here i don't know seems legit hacks
mode on what what how kaiba
final battle
fight
so this is it
i've saved my girl defeated the bad guy
and escaped the game after living two
years of a torturous life in it
i guess there's only one more thing to
do
why sword art online again